People wish upon a star because they
have some intuition that aiming above
the mundane has the potential to
transform themselves.
They make a wish.
Well,
if you're gonna,
make a wish.
You should aim at something high and
even just aiming at that is more likely
to make the wish come true and this is
not a metaphor.
You know,
I have this program which you guys are
going to do called the future authoring
program is one of two assignments.
One is that you write an autobiography.
That's the past authoring.
The other is that you write a plan for
the future.
That's the future authoring.
I would recommend that you get started
on those right now,
like not right now,
but like really soon because they're
harder than you think and some of you
are going to write like 15,000
words.
You're going to get sucked right in.
This happens all the time.
You're going to get sucked right into it
and so you write an autobiography
because you need to know where you are
and who you are right now because how
the hell are you going to plot a pathway
to the future?
Unless you know where you are and then
you need to write about the future
because you going to hit something
unless he aim at it,
that's for sure.
And lots of times people won't admit
what they want because they're afraid.
The reason they're afraid is because if
you specify what you want,
you've specified your conditions of
failure.
You know when you fail and it's better
just to keep it foggy.
It's like,
well,
I don't know if I'm succeeding or
failing,
but you know,
I can't really tell while.
Great.
Except you can't hit anything you don't
aim at.
And so the future authoring program is
like a,
it's a,
an attempt to have you articulate your
character.
And so as the past authoring program,
who are you and you know,
the past authoring program and asked you
to break your life into the parks and
then to write about the emotional,
you know,
the things that you regard as important
important events that have shaped who
you are and you know,
you may find that some of those,
some of that writing makes you
emotional.
I would say if you have a memory that's
more than 18 months old roughly
speaking,
and when you bring it to mind it,
it has an emotional impact,
especially in negative emotional impact.
There's.
It's like part of your soul is stuck
back there and I know that's a
metaphorical way of thinking about it,
but what I mean is that
the reason that you still experience the
emotion is because you have not solved
the problem that that situation face do
with.
It might be a real problem.
Like maybe you got tangled up with
someone who was really bad and that's
rough man,
because you got to come up with a theory
of malevolence to deal with something
like that and that's no joke,
but if it's still produces emotion,
it means you haven't solved the problem
and and your.
Your brain is still pegging it as
threat.
It's,
it's a part of your territory that you
did not master threat,
threat,
and until you take it apart and
articulation really helps,
that writing really helps that then
you're not going to free yourself from
its grip and that what might not be that
pleasant.
I mean this is one of those situations
were doing,
it tends to produce a detriment in
people's mood in the short term,
but quite radical improvements,
three to six months down the road,
you know,
and it's often the case that you
unfortunately have to do something you
don't want to do in order to progress.
It's very,
very common.
So in the future authoring program asks
you about different dimensions of your
life,
like because you're,
you know,
you can think of yourself as a
personality inside your head,
but your nested in systems that
transcend you and they're just as real
as whatever's in your head.
It's like,
well,
what do you need for life?
Well,
that's pretty easy actually.
Some friends,
that's a good thing.
Intimate relationship,
Family,
you know either the one you're going to
produce or the one that you come from
where people to some degree of love and
care for one another.
That's a good thing to work on.
You need,
you need some plan for your career.
You've got to fit in somewhere that
people regard as important and that
they'll trade with you so that you can
live.
You need something worthwhile to do with
the time that you're not at work and you
need to pay attention to your mental and
physical health and you need to regulate
your use of substances,
which is a strange one,
but alcohol does lots of people in so
it's worth.
It's worth thinking about.
That's why we put it in there,
so then it's like,
okay,
what the hell do you want?
What do you want from your friends?
What do you want from your family?
What do you want from your career?
If you could have what you want to.
That's what the program asks you.
Three to five years down the road,
you get to have what you want.
Now I'm assuming that you're going to
approach this like,
you know,
reasonable adults and not like 13 year
old dreamers.
I think I want the most expensive yacht
in the world.
It's like fine,
but you know,
that isn't really what it's supposed to
be more concentrating on your character
and so then it asks you to write for 15
minutes without thinking too much about
grammar or sentence structure.
Any of that,
but what your life could be like three
to five years down the road if you were
treating yourself like someone you cared
for and you were helping them figure out
what they wanted and then it asks you to
do the same thing in reverse,
which is to think about the ways that
you're radically insufficient and your
faults and everyone knows this.
I think,
you know,
maybe not,
but everyone has a sense of if they were
going to degenerate,
how they would do it.
You know,
some people would be an alcoholic,
some people would be a street person.
It's like there's some doom thing out
there that's got your name on it.
If you're particularly in cautious and
you know,
don't.
And let things fall apart,
so want you to write about that.
What do you not want to have happened in
three to five years?
And there's psychological reasons for
this.
A one is if you have something to aim
for,
that's a source of positive emotion
because your positive emotion is mostly
generated by evidence that you're moving
towards something that you value.
It's not generated so much by
accomplishing something because when you
accomplish something,
you're just left with the problem of
whatever you're going to do next.
So you graduate from university.
It's like,
you know,
Hooray.
One day you're at the peak of your
undergraduate university career.
The next day you're unemployed and
looking for a bad job at starbucks.
So,
you know,
well you see what I mean is,
it's,
it's that,
you know,
one problem that you solve is replaced
by another problem.
And so the idea that you're going to be
happy when you solve all your problems,
it's like good luck with that theory.
But,
but you know,
if you're aiming at something worthwhile
and you really believe it's worthwhile
and you've thought it through,
you know,
so that you're not weak,
you're not weak,
you've got your damn arguments,
my mustard.
Then when you make progress even a
little bit,
you think,
hey,
that's all right,
and you get a little kick,
a little dopamine kick,
and that's what you want because that's
where your positive emotion comes from.
You can use cocaine if you want,
but,
but you know,
that tends to have relatively
detrimental medium to longterm
consequences,
but it activates the same system.
So you have to be aiming at something
and you should be aiming at something
that's realistic that you want,
that you could get,
you know,
like,
not easily because if it's easy,
in some sense you've already got it.
It's got to push you.
And that's part of the pleasure
actually,
because there's two things that you want
to do when you're pursuing something
that's important and one of them is to
get the thing that's important.
But the other is,
is to make yourself better at pursuing
things.
Right?
So,
so you can get both of those at the same
time you,
you,
you're aiming at something and you're
increasing your competence.
It's like that's a good deal.
That's a good deal and there's a lot of
intrinsic meaning to be felt in that and
then the second half of the program you,
you write out a plan for how you're
going to do it and how you're going to
keep yourself on track and you're going
to write about why it would be good for
you if you did this and why it would be
good for your family and what possible
benefits it would have to the community
because you want to nail this thing down
and then you want to figure out what
kind of obstacles are going to come up
and how you might overcome them and how
you might keep yourself on track and all
of that.
And we know because we've actually done
a lot of research on this particular
program that if university students do
this and this is more true.
If they're not too well oriented to
begin with.
If University students do this,
they're about 25 percent less likely to
drop out,
which is lot and about their grade point
average increases about 20 percent.
So Hooray for that,
you know,
because you never know when you develop
an intervention,
if it's gonna work,
there's also evidence but not from my
lab.
That doing such things improves your
physical health and I think the reason
for that is that,
you know,
when you go over your autobiography and
you scour out those negative places that
you're sort of dragging along with you,
it lowers your overall stress load
because your brain is kinda.
I think it's calculating how dangerous
the world is by attending to the ratio
of successes to failures that you've had
in your life.
Something like that.
And so you know,
if there are holes in your map that you
could still fall through,
then your brain regards the territory
still as a bit on the dangerous side and
then you more prepared for emergency
action and that's hard on you.
So you want to go back there and fix up
those experiences is to the degree that
you can't.